we are here with the gorgeous talented
and beautifully smelling michelle
pfeiffer
michelle um that parlays into the fact
that you have two new henry rose scents
that you're torn between releasing next
year this will be your tenth yes scent
that is so incredible
and um we actually uh ingratiated our
audience thanks to your help before the
show everybody smelled samples of both
scents
on beautiful blotters that your company
provided and they voted on their
favorite we have a and b
mm-hmm
uh-huh um i have not heard the results
of this have you no is it in here
somewhere um it will be in a second all
right so we are gonna smell scent a
would you please uh tell anyone who may
be watching
what the scent is
it's a floral
and it is uh
it has orange blossom it has violet leaf
it has
some sandalwood i love it okay so i'm so
excited we don't know the winning scent
um but before we reveal it uh there is
some audience members who did
get a sense memory evoked um and the
fragrances reminded them of something
samantha um will you please hello
samantha um which scent did you choose
and what did it remind you of i chose a
i'm kind of obsessed with it but i grew
up in the pacific northwest and every
summer we'd go hiking on mount rainier
and it was like iconic scent of walking
through those huge wildflower fields
and it doesn't matter how much you've
hiked how sweaty you are it still smells
amazing out there and i don't know
that's just kind of what came to mind
okay yeah that's a great story i love
that i know i love that tanya uh where
are you and which scent i'm right here
oh hi tanya hi
um
which scent did you get drawn into and
what did it remind you of i selected b
okay it reminded me of
being a child and my mother and my aunts
would get dressed to go out to these
social engagements
and they would put on the hair
the
stockings the
everything and then they would spray on
the perfume and then they'd just walk
through it
and it just brought back memories
because when they would leave i would go
and try on their wigs and their shoes
and put on their makeup everything else
so that's what it reminded me of and it
it it has a sexiness b like you know i
remember when if
if my mom didn't take me to the club um
when i was growing up if for some reason
she went out on her own that night and
then came home i did love the way she
smelled when she would i would call your
description of the fragrance home alone
i like that which now is my new favorite
thing
to do i like to be home alone um
okay well it's time to reveal which
scent the audience chose okay i'm very
excited um okay
the winner is with the 66
of the
vote
is
a i
had a feeling
[Music]
and which is your preferred i
i am a bee
i also think you can't lose because
i oh whoa you know what
yeah
a
you know what we're going to release
them both
[Applause]
i think a might be a bit more of a
universal it might be and i think you
know
our line has really really needed this
this is the kind of knowledge and
passion that you all need to know
[Applause]
i'm so happy to tell you
that you're each going home with a henry
rose discovery set today
i mean thank you for that
[Applause]
it has to end i'm sorry
[Music]
you